BUT I WANT TO TALK AGAIN
ABOUT OBVIOUSLY THE TRAGEDY THAT
HAPPENED.
THIS WEEK, THE EMERGENCE OF
DYLANN ROOF'S WHITE POWER
MANIFESTO AND HATE-STAGRAM
PHOTOS DID LITTLE TO ALLEVIATE
ANY CONFUSION ABOUT WHY HE DID
IT.
ABOUT WHY THIS WHITE
RACIST'S RACIST RACE EVASIONS
FOR ASSASINATING NINE
CHURCHGOERS WHILE RACISTING
RACE-ORIC.
I GUESS WE'LL JUST NEVER
KNOW WHY HE DID IT.
NOW YOU MAY THINK A TRAGEDY
SUCH AS THIS WOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNE TIME TO DISCUSS
THE COMPLEX VARIETY OF DEEP
SEEDED, UNEXAMINED ISSUES AND
FAILING THAT PERMEATE AMERICAN
CULTURE LIKE A SUBTERRANEAN
FAULT LINE THAT MOST ONLY NOTICE
UPON SEISMIC ERUPTIONS, ABOVE A
SIX OR SEVEN ON THE RICHTER
SCALE.
IT TURNS OUT, THIS IS NOT A GOOD
TIME.
>> THE RACE TO POLITICIZE
THE SENSELESS SOUTH CAROLINA
CHURCH SHOOTING TRAGEDY.
>> SO THEY COULDN'T WAIT?
>> YOU COULD HAVE WAITED FOR
SOME OF THIS.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN BURIED OUR
DEAD YET.
>> BEFORE THE BODIES HAVE EVEN
BEEN BURIED.
>> THEY TRY AND BLAME GUNS
AND DO EVERYTHING BUT IT IS
MISDIRECTED.
>> THE PRESIDENT, HE IS BLAMING
GUNS, LIBERALS POLITICIZEING
THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT GENERALLY
DEALS WITH THIS WHOLE ISSUE
POLITICALLY  RATHER THAN
SUBSTANTIVELY.
>> THE BODIES AREN'T COLD
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE TRYING
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS OF IT,
AND IT'S FANKLY DISGUSTING.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE A
SICKNESS LIKE, OH, WAIT. TRAGEDY
HAPPENS.
LET'S SEE HOW WE CAN ADVANCE OUR
NARRATIVE.
>> Jon: YES, IT'S A SICKNESS,
THIS RUSH TO USE TRAGEDY TO
ADVANCE YOUR NARRATIVE.
COMBINE THAT WITH AN INABLILTY
FOR SELF-EXAMINATION, AND
ALMOST COMICAL DEGREE OF
SELF-EXCULPABLE RHETORIC,
FLAG PINS, A LITTLE BIT OF
LEG AND A COMPLETE IMMUNITY
00:01:43,904 --> 00:00:00,000
TO IRONY, YOU GOT YOURSELF A
FULL BLOWN CASE OF FOXABETES.